yeah
once across the other lines actually
kind of start moving around so question
is whether or not they move around the
same amount every time or if it's like
unpredictable
we were trying to maybe see it as
possibly drive it bar with needs better
I mean probably better than
yes sir the general strategy
and my strategy is to find the areas
where things are changing the simplest
places
and but we have no data there's some
default big boundaries and so oftentimes
we can see those
as a kind of hot dogs and the variable
list of data and
yes pesky where it's dropping
that's what this big gasps data so the
truck driver really kids there's no
picture coming from
[Music]
they completely from this
so once we do a little bit more refining
on this we're thinking of trying to oh
thanks is it my only Wi-Fi
yeah ah Street okay
[Music]
what are they complaining
yeah they complain all you want the
tripod man we don't have it you can't be
nice to people on the Internet yeah
that's true
if you yeah and yeah it's so rude that
there's that mount right there and we're
just holding this one that one's
beautifully mounted but whatever after
yeah yeah sorry it's this one sorry the
iPhone 10 - 10 - this is a nice phone
George I put a little program actually
really get it yeah yeah the battery life
lasts seven days Wow it's true honestly
guys were selling too many cartoons
don't know George
not always by always by Colin if you
wait
[Music]
yeah it's also cheese we're also kind of
shooting ourselves in the foot no no
feature $1500 carpenters that's a
[Music]
Rihanna's album around the comet Encke
need a cassette and basically were able
to run the incident region model trade
on data's on top city and we basically
tried to classify the images you can
[Music]
and one of the other projects we wanted
to do was to new even trade up on the
common Thank You data set but later I
noticed had the data so wasn't good
enough there's like a lot of missing
people
and yet they don't have Lane
[Music]
every single part always going to be
yeah because they labor the road is
called
so if you want to like process your own
video three to eight hundred one day I
did this there's quite a bit of
difference is you can see up there
there's a sorry that the yellow email
[Music]
in the side maybe you can see all
useless past basis this specific video
was not actually referred using like the
toy word responses but I have a feeling
we actually made if we convert the
output to how we did in that other
example
nice
[Laughter]
yeah so it's a shared memory
[Music]
so I just want to show an example so I
was able to get the image stream into
Ross and then as a result be able to
load up one of my loss packages which
takes in a single image and so this is
our business it's a tool that's built
into rasta like these are when you when
you get messages you have tools in the
ecosystem so we're going to see that
this is the image so you can see like
so that's what I worked on it is quite
slow you see there's quite a delay of
course you have inferencing on the GPU
but there is a bottleneck with the
actual bridge that's because I actually
pick up the messages from the CM field
not directly from the shared memory
message interface so I think in the
future I'd like to work on into advanced
this is to go directly from that shared
memory interface directly to walls so
this is the one I was only getting able
to get the invitation to cross I've been
working on getting to a gamma tree data
as well so that peasants I have able to
get that right but once I'm able to beat
up than you'd be able to visualize the
odometry over time and use two minutes
to spare
[Music]
who's next
Oh
what do you think you - yeah oh wow that
wasn't a joke Tom the Apple pen pen very
similar very silence a pencil they make
pencils they talk will you make pencils
we're competing without
[Music]
[Music]
you have this is
this is anything on a particular image
well you can also do flexes but we enter
you have some region that you dislike
left out and then you want to and then
you can just navigate yeah something at
this day so it's hard to see so which is
working on this and I decide to I just
want to write these features for better
annotation so what you can do here is
that again you can further position and
if you have some sports left if you just
become the flutter no more than anything
for it particularly but one of the
reasons to do this was to you leverage
one of the things that I was checking
out words it hops imaged it which is a
really cool so what this allows us to do
is here's some
I get it so this is a MOSFET exist so
you just see this but if I'm asked for
the whole ebay then you actually see it
if this is there so you can see like
there could differ so if people want to
improve some segmentation and everyone
if they share it and then they can like
send a pull request and then pull
request we will get negative so we
another ambitious for slightly this TV
thing wants to comment and apologize
from UI which works on my back but is
not working but basically you can like
make your annotation download so this
you got a minute so you to pay attention
because this stuff's all gonna go live
and you guys are gonna label the 10k
this is actually the highest leverage
way in a long time for you to actually
improve open pilot our segment is total
garbage that underlies all the open
pilot models so if you're upset that
open pilot doesn't detect the lanes by
you you're gonna be spending a few hours
and come pencil content sweet nice cool
[Applause]
did everyone realize that I spelled
limit wrong on every single sign no one
no one caught that limps over there - oh
there's one good eye okay but that one
there's no eye on that one yeah I wish
it was on purpose no it's embarrassing I
was like how did I miss so many eyes so
many do I would I know I'm with myself I
don't know what happened well they do
and you think you're doing an eye
because you do the movement of the M and
the T you know it's all very very NSYNC
it's tough Wow
I mean these people are rude about the
tripe I'm gonna shake a little bit you
know there we go shake them yeah yo and
get ready for column pencil guys yeah
he's possible
join us and discord for the greatest
common crowd source Hertz since like the
last one of these we did mm-hmm
no but like this one matters the comic
colouring Dana is all this matters it's
a lot more well thought out ten thousand
images
I believe in you guys can't pencil the
reason I believe in you is your pull
request is gonna be reviewed by the
community yeah and if you're not pixel
accurate it all those labels they're
gonna boo it's just gonna this might
work this is great reflection of the con
neon sign yep
the buncher doesn't know about 2x DPI
they started and first thing is can it
be possible now checking if doors are
open or closed so the time
or that we were checking the old sensor
that's a feature we don't want to
disengage it the passenger remove this
highly concerning the test authority
finding bugs
what's the mountain
and over charger battery is that what B
is no I always wonder that it's like
driving slow oh that's a great feature
[Music]
but yeah it is preparing out which one
if you're making what a port or
something like that all the variables
there's one complexion
yeah we found out that after we catch
after all the data
it's just nicer to be actually
so we work on you also work on a
different one where we were trying to
say give in
cool
[Applause]
sweet 2/3 you want to comment 2/3 bill
to free up
how's YouTube 58 almost pathetic
is it go tell your friends come watch
our Channel
oh I'll tweet maybe you know for people
who didn't think that comma is actually
gonna do this we did and everyone in
Disco oh yeah yeah that's better
okay okay yeah can you do that yeah
yeah we can turn off the me on it guess
[Music]
three
thank you very Chris I think so too
don't mind me just having a conversation
you know
perfect already linked it I mean the
idea was it's very difficult to make out
with signal to work and so we set out to
do is they try to to get an automatic
filtering signals and ultimately to
suggest from from all the logs from a
signal box I'll open pilot be able to
know which can be steering acceleration
or braking so we didn't get so we took
the log and exported everything in CSV
files what we had all the data based in
reference with respect
[Music]
so this by the way just basically
reading the whole message of all I bytes
all the vines yeah yeah but what if what
if it's in the least significant byte
yeah yeah yeah so for some of the
messages here but the whole make sense
even message you got lucky because in
the first two bytes
[Music]
right so anyway after that hmm the idea
was okay so now that we see that can we
actually train a neural network to
differentiate between the two so we go
to the file before and picatinny friend
shorter random is second actually try to
differentiate between steering and um
steering signals and the accuracy test
appreciated of being 89% which happy cat
okay
not for like generative you see but at
least in the URL for showing would not
be stealing signal yes yes just to show
you what it looks like so I can I can
run this for example this random is like
this so of course if you run this is
probably the 70s
mr. bousley back here I'm Danny's
smelling good actually I mean how many
frames you putting in
[Music]
[Music]
are you doing YouTube how many we got
130 130 they complaining about the
microphone they were complaining about
the mic everyone I talked yeah you're
very close you're upset 20%
oh my battery nobody lost forever oh
that's true oh I was worried cuz the 90%
more normal yeah exactly and I found 10
died so quickly right
so hi everybody I'm Campbell I took a
bus here from Berkeley I decided to take
on this cabana challenge auger printing
so basically Auto fingerprinting in the
Candida there's information about the
car and normally through Savannah you
need to manually choose the DBC file and
interpret all that Candida and so I
built a feature in Cabana that can
automatically detect the vehicle can
automatically applied the proper right
now it's not automatically deploy
applying it but it's kind of giving
smarter suggestions then available and
then I also went around and kind of
talked to people that used Cabana I
figured out you know what they liked
about it was they didn't I kind of made
some some UI changes I had it more data
to the UI and kind of made it more
modular and also enabled the ability to
customize the repository that you're
sourcing here you can see file open and
then just generally went around and kind
of reverse engineered the app in you
know maybe later I'm planning on
cleaning up the work that I did on this
and submitting a full request and I'm
also you know I've gotten a feel for
this
people work night and you know for
feedback if anybody has a new feature
request I you know it's complicated it's
not super hard to work with I yeah I
really enjoyed it I enjoyed you know
talking to everybody that they didn't
fix me enough making you better 48 hours
yeah cool cool challenge and I also kind
of service more information from the can
files that were previously available so
kind of you know went through the
process of interpreting is this Candida
and displaying it on the front end for
for the ability but kind of manipulated
on cavana
I wasn't able to get all of the canned
data converted into bytes so you could
play around with it but that kind of got
some of the legwork gained and had some
of the signals like some of the live
tracking data from the path planning
data and more of the car parameters able
to be accessed in Quebec I yeah cool
[Music]
[Applause]
I one more
[Music]
oh thank you thank you thank you you
know what I want to see just how long
George's battery lasts at this point
that's gonna help him out and then I
figured hello youtubers welcome to the
intermission it takes people time to
plug their stuff in you know that we
have to keep you entertained constantly
it's so important yeah but you can't lie
there's some people who lie up yeah
yeah but then people are so mad about
the video you know it's a real delicate
balance Wow charging we have so much
here I know so much plugs it's crazy
keep talking George 550 people watching
you interested we sold a lot of shoes
[Music]
[Music]
yeah they're great software did the
interview process very fun I wanna give
you myself
fun
4114
one fine it's fun it's just fine show
but driving is chill if you buy a comic
- but don't buy calm - result already
yeah now I'm done with that I'm done
with that reckless played out woman's
without the I was happy - what are you
gonna do - the screens not work when you
want to plug them and plug them back in
oh no Nvidia fix your driver Nvidia if
you're watching fix your driver way mo
if you're watching shutdown you'll never
make money
[Laughter]
zooks if you're watching we are hiring
[Laughter]
we are reaching from a big level five
company today
I'm sorry level four
hmm I think the presentation is gonna
get down here
Oh what yup yup just the monitor is uh
some things that monitor don't judge
based on that chip that's right
computer because the Nvidia drivers are
terrible going on plugging replugged
your mana Derek over here yeah you will
regret it okay
self-drive that system program problem
detected started after I installed the
Nvidia drivers by the way what guys
manager runs on Ubuntu now it's like a
neon but it's Ubuntu people are so quick
to drop when this dream goes out well
we're down to 93 people that's terrible
yeah stream has experience what was this
gonna work with the webcam yeah yo
that's pretty exciting and it's a new
i/o this is exciting the model I wrote
this code so the brakes first oh no no
you know the problem is we gotta run
calibration D open up another window
yeah that's the rain by the way it never
self-drive location date it just stops
going on da / calibration date Wow
that's be crazy yeah fingers crossed
that's super combo wait is the framerate
right why isn't the model running should
be running right we need anything else
oh maybe it's there I don't think it's
working
no I don't know restart calibration day
restart your model he's not gonna be
both model he's not gonna run the model
unless nobody should run the model
because the super combo Oh control see
model the entirety of the world didn't
change you I know see Molly do you run
it again
no it's not right yeah click on though
yeah but don't we are consultants or
yeah
Oh
you know why do you have a daily start
running camera D - man on yeah oh that
thing lies and says to our star oh you
have helped to do that so guys I should
start model D then it worked really
three frames this is exciting who's
gonna be the first person to go out and
put a YouTube video of driving with
their logitech webcam the future is
decentralized all you need is this all
you need is a webcam and a gaming
computer and open source software to
drive your car
yep and a panda I don't know that but
there was the yeah there was someone
happened after that they were used yeah
there you go
No
we can you can show it on a laptop yeah
let's do that
[Laughter]
so hi Kenzie I'm super happy and proud
to be here I appreciate you all giving
me a chance um so I'm probably by me not
probably I'm definitely by orders of
magnitude the least experienced person
here so at the very beginning of this
event George mentioned two reasons why
we're here one of them was as a
recruiting event to find machine
learning talent clearly I don't fall
into that bucket yet so the other one
was to beta test some software so I was
more focused on that aspect as a person
who is maybe more savvy than some people
but is still just like trying to figure
things some of these things out so I
guess I was representing that end of the
user pool perhaps but in any case also
George mentioned externalizing things
and so I decided to focus on that Jo
[Music]
wanting to see torque displayed maybe in
the EON but an indication in the
meanwhile I started working on showing
torque but not in the EON instead in the
in the UI interface so um I'm not sure
how many all worked on this aspect but
there's the unlocker which we start
running and then it starts spitting out
data and then we can run the UI module
on top of that so
let me just first demonstrate the UI as
it was originally received by me so iris
is currently exists on the repo so we
get the data running here off of a
public route public on logger thanks to
Andy age - yes so you can't start
spitting out data come over here and
[Music]
yeah we run the UI and the UI should pop
up there it does so for those who have
tested it this is what the UI looks like
there is an issue here right off the bat
which is basically that the resolution
of either the VM and/or my Mac are
making it such that the lower part of
the UI is cut off I don't think I have
that's fine I don't think I have the
capabilities necessarily to change that
I tried to mess around with the
resolution I could not get the bottom
part of the UI to show up but I was
intending to add torque to this anyway
so that is the UI as it exists and so I
started making some changes on the route
to getting torque to show up so I'll
just quickly go through these I know
what these are faces so view short
presentations so the first thought I had
was to make it resizable I started
digging around in the UI and also one of
the UI libraries and I was able to get
resizable but that did not make it such
that you could scroll things I've done
the next thing which is that okay so I
have a screenshot here of the UI where
you can see that UI is five years old
now oh yeah I wrote that during the
smoking weed era of
[Laughter]
so here's a speech I made of the next
part which is that I started messing
about the elements and I appreciate very
parsimonious commenting I think that
that's a typical circumstances
indicative of good coding and so that
was the case here so how does it start
manipulating things to see what was what
so first thing I found is that this text
was the thing that was off-screen so I
changed the orientation to be zero zero
so that I could see the text and it
looks better on the picture looks like
the tussle looks I agree yeah that's
that's one of the things I realized so
thanks Tesla
so yeah so this text which is not
visible on the UI with my current setup
is now visible and I agree with George
it does look better with the picture as
the background so but then I noticed
there's this new line break between
those two sets of data so I asked Gregg
is there a reason for that because you
can see actually apparently one of the
ways in the smoking weed era to show a
new library is to just do none and that
added the line break so but clearly that
wasn't Adam for no reason so I asked
great great what the reason was he
wasn't quite sure but he guessed that
there is some sort of categorical of
separation there so in an attempt to
retain the category separation
categorical separation without without
having a new line there because it was
taking it more space I just removed the
new line and then change this lower
France to orange had to find out how to
do all that and was successful and
there's gonna be sort of a reveal at the
end or whatever I'm going to show you
all better than me anyway
give us the reveal in one minute ok ok
ok
[Music]
the other change I did was there was
there's a video that shows the
trajectories on top of the area of
interest and I wanted to put that up
here because there's a lot of wasted
space just from a usability perspective
there's a lot of wasted space going on
up here and basically anything outside
of the bounding box we don't really care
about so from a visual perspective it's
better just to have it in there
so I kept this text oh I moved it over
here I kept it up here put the put the
other box up here student vidiian video
which is a shout out of it and then yeah
and then certainly something was talking
text moving things around massage but
then then the plot moves out of the way
so I started massaging plot spacing in
anyway let's see what we got MIUI oh so
so yeah so now we have the video in
video so as we're taking advantage of
the wasted space above all so it's
aligned with the image below in order to
basically have a little easier visual
acuity this is still taking advantage of
being on top of the background and now
because the default setting on the text
were enabled and brake light is black we
can actually see you know when it's not
being engaged effectively also I moved
this map up so we could make sure and
see the car and the reason why this text
is alright to overlap is because the
farther we get away from the front of
the car the less effectively so it
doesn't really enjoy the on the you or
whatever the debugging aspect of which
is what we're using this for and then I
got the plot I you know matplotlib as we
all know is not easy to use but I was
able to massage these into space so that
we're still seeing the data and the last
thing that I was working on but wasn't
able to do was get these labels to match
the color of the gas line that would
seem to be that makes a lot more sense
than a little parenthesis that we have
the UI has not been shown much love okay
so now the very last that was that was
that's mostly what I did and then the
very last little thing is that as we can
see here with this system is based on
pygame and pygame works quite well but
here's the thing pygame quite
understandably has self promotion needs
and so as you can see every time
we invoke the UI pikin gets their little
advertisement in that hello from the PI
game community which is overwhelming
okay well so then I didn't like that I
don't want I mean no offense the flag
game we love them and all that but I
just personally didn't want to see that
so I first got rid of it no but we still
want to prompt so I added a combo prompt
[Applause]
everyone in 2% preventer
no yes No all right I said we were gonna
shout it out but we're not really gonna
[Music]
do that
people love dashboards I don't know why
and so basically what I did was I went
to the comma 2092 caiman team and looked
around the process readers to a
non-processed readers it's running
currently on a branch and microphone if
you want to go take it do whatever you
want with it but it's really cute I to
be aware of that
instead of numpy basically just
converting all everything this one it
should be what is that
yes we're downloading the entire 22 k-19
data set right and then we go and we
extract all the values which was kind of
hard to do but that's good so I just
simple ones for loops and then I brought
them in and I made a dashboard it
doesn't really work but it should
eventually we have some display issues
around San Jose for some reason and so
you just go down here just running off
iPod widgets as well a few other simple
technologies and you should be able to
just put spacer and we'll get the full
dear friend there with the query and
then we can do is coordinate map which
is not gonna be out
it was taken I like this one I think we
can do better and I think we can scale
it and then the speed verse bearing just
to show what kind of possible and this
is the Geo map to show that a math was
supposed to be there but I couldn't get
a display that's all okay yeah can you
tell people they're asking you go cool
okay um so remember how I said YouTube
was gonna come in the back to the
judgment session they're not sorry you
two bye bye you two
[Music]